un zoológico tiene 15 pingüinos
emperador que constituyen el 30 por
ciento del total del número de pingüinos
en el zoológico cuántos pingüinos hay en
el zoológico entonces sea x el número de
pingüinos el número total de pingüinos
que hay en el zoológico en zoológico nos
dice que 30 por ciento de esos son
pingüinos emperador los cuales son 15
así es que nos están diciendo que el 30
por ciento de x es igual a 15 otra
manera de expresar esto es si ponemos 30
por ciento en decimal sería 0.30 de x
0.30 por x esto es igual a 15 es igual a
15 vamos a resolver para x dividiendo
ambos lados entre punto 30 entonces
dividimos entre punto 30 el lado
izquierdo y dividimos entre punto 30 el
lado derecho ahora tenemos
el lado izquierda hemos despejado la x y
el lado derecho nos queda 15 / 0.30 para
esto vamos a hacer algo de aritmética
vamos a dividir entonces 15 entre 0.30 y
vamos a revisar lo que son las
divisiones con números decimales para
hacer esta división hay que multiplicar
por 100 a ambos lados vamos a
multiplicar por 100 el lado izquierdo y
el lado derecho para que no se altere
multiplicar por si en un número es mover
el punto decimal dos lugares a la
derecha y lo mismo hacemos para el
dividendo para el 15 movemos el punto
decimal dos lugares a la derecha para
obtener 1500 y ya tenemos que el número
de veces que cabe 30 en 1500 es igual al
número de veces que cabe punto 30 en 15
hagamos esta operación déjame pasarla
aquí en limpio para que quede más
ordenado esto lo único que hicimos fue
mover el punto decimal dos lugares hacia
la derecha es decir multiplicamos tanto
el numerador como el denominador por 100
lo cual no cambio el valor de la
fracción hagamos entonces la operación
cuántas veces cabe 30 en 1500 no caben 1
no caben 15 en ciento
acabe 5 veces 5 por 30 y 150 que
restamos nos queda 0 bajamos el 0 0
entre 30 es igual a 0 así es que 30
acabe en 1550 veces que es lo mismo que
15 entre punto 30 por lo cual el valor
de x es igual a 50 y podemos verificar
esto si multiplicamos punto 30 por 50
vamos a obtener 15 ahora hay otra manera
de hacer esto podríamos considerar la
fracción de pingüinos emperador con
respecto al total de pingüinos en el
zoológico podríamos considerar entonces
que 15
15 sobre el número total de pingüinos
del zoológico es igual a 30 por ciento
treinta por ciento quiere decir 30 de
cada 100 o treinta dividido entre 100
así es que 30 de cada 100 y aquí ya
podemos resolver para x y una manera muy
fácil de ver la solución es mira para ir
de 30 a 15
hay que dividir entre 2 que tiene que
ser lo mismo para ir de 100 a equis
tenemos que vivir 100 entre 2 para
obtener que x es igual a 50 15 entre 50
es lo mismo que 30 entre 100 así que el
número total de pingüinos emperador es
igual a 50